ce sont deux manufactures de renommée
mondiale
buffet crampon et henri selmer sont
pourtant situé à quelques mètres l'une
de l'autre
la première est leader mondial dans la
fabrication de clarinette
la seconde est une référence dans la
création de saxophone les deux
établissements ont ouvert leurs portes à
l'occasion de l'eole factory festival
pour la première édition du all factory
festival on a travaillé conjointement
pour pouvoir essayer d'ouvrir ses
grandes manufactures au public et aussi
parce qu'on est bien seul week end
patrimoine comme errol factory
travailler autour de tout ce qu'un
instrument à vent et patrimoine musical
du territoire ça nous semblait très
important de pouvoir coupler une visite
plus des manufactures avec le début du
festival
grâce à ces portes ouvertes le public a
pu découvrir le travail minutieux des
employés ils sont 500 à travailler henry
selmer et 200 ch et buffet crampon
alors là exactement là à l'heure
actuelle sans pas me passer à l'huile
à
les corps donc gens en train de polir
l'intérieur du bois pour que l'eau et
l'air circule au maximum et plus droit
possible pour que tous puissent évacuer
pour que le son ne soit pas perturbé pas
qu'il y ait de quoi que
sonore pour les musiciens nous avons un
éclaté de saxophones c'est à dire toutes
les pièces qui représente les montagnes
saxophone qui sont fixés sur un cadre
c'est pour répondre le mans bien montrer
aux gens toutes les pièces qui sont sur
un instrument l'occasion aussi pour les
artistes de pouvoir découvrir comment
leurs instruments sont fabriqués je ne
savais pas du tout comment les
saxophones et est fabriqué j'ai déjà
fait réparer mon saxo à de nombreuses
reprises mais je n'ai jamais vu ça c'est
vraiment cool
les deux manufactures sont implantés à
mantes la ville depuis 1850 pour buffet
crampon et 1919 pour henri selmer
[Musique]